In the vast world we live
in Various monsters
threaten humans
Many adventurers and
brave
men face
them
Alone Encounter Alright
let's go pup It's over huh
cute 4 choose strong yeah yeah
My name is
Kalo, a dark elf
.
If you want
to get on your knees, shouldn't
you take good care
of your hands
?  But
is it accumulating? q
I was stopped in the progressive form.Are you taking it out on me because I'm about to lose to the demon beasts
?
You probably won't cry a lot It's
true that the filming was
bad I'm sorry about that, but Khan is no good Don't get
caught up in this guy's pace
I'm sorry, I can't do it, Kira.
Well then, I
'll stop you when you get out of the door. Oh,
Mr.
Hayashi, please
come and have a party with me.
It seems like everyone can't talk to me
It seems like they think of me like a high-flying flower It
's bee poison
Yes, but I'm not a high-ranked adventurer,
so don't expect too much.
Well, I've been yelling at my stamina since a while
ago,
so it's good for the economy, is
n't it?
Let's go [music] After all, when you're done catching, you don't have to divide it into quick-hit layers
Please give me a lure aiming for two hearts
Wait, didn't you cast a fragile
Eva?
It
's too new to put on a hetero signal
, isn't it? Don't panic. It's not a big curse
.
I can't get away from you,
huh, did you get together yesterday?
Ms.
Kara
, you shouldn't raise your voice to girls Kara should be more considerate of the other person's feelings
gyao If you're going to have a party, you'll get
along very well, but
first of all, you'll be a bear to talk about, and you shouldn't start talking about Cedar in pain
.
There's no point in yelling at each other, so
we're going to have a discussion
.
Putting that aside,
why is this magical beast participating
in the discussion
?  Inside and people are the same living things Though the
shapes are different, we
can understand each other only when we treat each other with an additional spirit It's as if we
remembered for the first time  I hear that even among beasts,
those that have lived for a long time are highly intelligent and
have a wealth of experience.  Well,
I know about dragons, but
before asking for your opinion, I'm really sorry about the name
Zao.
It's
just that people mostly ask about our race
as a bear.
A job like Karacha Kara-chan
is the first to be targeted, so
it's the warriors who protect you.
Then, if you know how to behave
,
then And the defendant's
greenness is low, and although you're in a political party, your violent words suddenly came out.
The
bear elves are sensitive to people's negative emotions,
but maybe that feeling has
changed to Kara-chan's
room
.  The
point is, if you're going to form a party, both of you will
need each
other.One day, Yama will not be able to stay
more than 300 meters away
from Karlagen.I think it's important to always have respect and gratitude
.
I've lived a long time, so I
can
speak a strange human language.  You don't know, don't you? I have
n't been
sitting since the
3rd term.
It's only allowed when
you're talking to the
principal.
What are you talking about, bear
? This demon beast has lived for a long time
, isn't it?
Lets
I was talking to jt about investing
me
ah ah ah ah
what was
it
me
I feel like I
've been through a
terrible experience, but oh, I'm glad I woke up in the room.
Is that your house?
It was my fault for saying something rude.I'm sorry, but maybe you were the one who helped me.Well, it's not me.
I'm recovering from Bear Ion Well, it's
morning.
Breakfast is bread, please. Coffee should
have a lot of milk and sugar
.
It
was a terrible wound, so it's a one-time recovery.
It can't be done with magic, but it's hard to do it over and over again.
Thanks to Na-chan,
there seems to be no problem, but I can't understand
[Music] The
company meal
ao
Ah, the room where I was relieved.
I
did my best to use the recovery part,
but Hidaka was progressing, and somehow my body recovered.
I wonder if it's a few balls I
tried to get closer to the original face, but it
's a kettle and it
's cute with a nonchalant feeling
[Music]
No, I'm not screwing this
It's really bad or I couldn't do it all the way to the back But
it's a big video with this Bear
Do you have a fixed price god
?  Gaa
Did the hair on your face not heal completely?
The bear that asked for fish and
tried to return it to the face is full of
magic It
feels like it's halfway
Peru
Hmmm Gala Jeanne Ah
[music]
Guidance If I think about it, there's
no such thing as a certain painter
Actually, I really
want you to hate
me, but I'm completely back to normal,
but I'm used to being hated by people.
It's just like that, but what's the unity
?
Shameless coe is something like a dark blue It's a
half-hearted feeling
, is
n't it
?  At
that time,
there was a bear Beyer, who fought with various adventurers
Logo and E
Arumi is a caring person Bear
I'm sure you can get along well with Carla
Face  It's
okay to take your time a little more bear
Jean.
Even
if it's
a
surprise attack, I won't get away with it like this
.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, yeah  player
Don't forget that word and
let's keep the same
restoration date Is it
only here?
Hey kids,
why are you promised a
revenge match?
Can't you stop this
?
No, we're on good terms in real life, but you're deliberately having a
conversation with Enemy Oki.
I have to explain this.
Even
so, far from being grateful to someone who is a benefactor of life, even in the sound of life
.
It's
not like that, but I think it's a way of showing gratitude or respect to people who have worked hard.
If everyone wants to express their gratitude to
Urawa no matter what, then I'm not afraid
to accept that feeling
.
Did you get that song?
Of course
, it feels like it's more correct to just knock it down and wind it up as a
fair reward.
I'm sorry, but I
'm the one who's second-rate
.
I'm going to ask you about the party
ame
7th place ban
ran
[music]
c 3 e
aname
me
toni
[music]
ni ah ah ah
I was chic ran yeah yeah yeah
Hiro's going to be over by now. I'll let you
through, so
Mr. Mune told me to stop
.
Mr. B:
Ah
, I
once again felt keenly and fully with all my might, but it's
really no good
, isn't it
?
Please beat me
meme
[music] The
next subtitle is
Alvin, who ends up traveling with the healer Curler,
tries to continue his original purpose of collecting poison chambers
, but he is on the way to the graveyard.  And then all of a sudden
I got into a fight with a ghost
and I thought I cut my way through the streets in an unexpected way